Let us see what we learn about
the patterns that emerge.
We will show that the
clusters are interpretable
and reveal unique patterns
of diagnostic history
among the population.
We selected six patterns to
present in this lecture--
Cluster 1, 6, and
7, in Cost Bucket 2,
and Clusters 4, 5, and
10, in Cost Bucket 3.
The first pattern shows the
occurrence of chest pain
three months before
the heart attack.
Note that the red dots depict
the visits per diagnosis
for patients in Cluster
1-- this is, we think,
Bucket 2-- and the blue
dots depict the visits
per diagnosis for patients
in Bucket 2 throughout.
Note the very
significant increase
for visits related
to chest pains
three months before the event.
About 17, three months
before for the red patients,
and about 1 and 1/2 visits
for the blue patients.
The next pattern reveals
an increasing occurrence
of chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease, COPD, for short.
Patients from
Cluster 7 in Bucket 2
have regular doctor
visits for COPD.
Note that nine months
before, we have
4 and 1/2 visits
versus 0.5 visits.
Six months before, we have
almost 7 visits versus 1/2
a visit, and three
months before, we
have 9 visits versus
1/2 a visit for COPD,
so a clear increasing pattern.
The next pattern shows
gradually increasing occurrence
of anemia.
The red line shows the
patient's in Cluster 4
increasingly visit the doctor
for anemia from nine months
on before the event.
Nine months before, members
have an average of 9 visits
to the doctor for anemia.
This increases to an average
of 11 visits six months
before the event, and
then an average of 15
visits three months before
the event, a clear increasing
pattern.
The final pattern shows
the occurrence of diabetes
as a pattern for heart attacks.
It is well known that
both types 1 and 2
diabetes are associated with
accelerated atherosclerosis,
one of the main causes of
myocardial infarction-- heart
attacks, that is.
Well known diagnoses
associated with heart attacks,
such as diabetes, hypertension,
and hyperlipidemia,
characterize many of the
patterns of the consistency
of care throughout all of the
cost buckets and clustering
models.
You observe a difference,
here, of the number
of visits for diabetes
for the population
that had the event versus
the other population.